Hiring is as,
as important as any other thing you
could possibly do.
And probably if not the hardest,
one of the hardest things to do,
you know,
whether,
can you really get the full measure of
somebody's in a,
I don't care,
six meetings,
which would be extreme,
right?
And by the way,
if you get the full measure of that
person,
can't you understand how that person
will operate within your environment?
Right?
Cause just because somebody comes in and
fail,
it doesn't mean they're,
they're a failure or a bad executive.
It just might be that their personality
or their expertise didn't match,
uh,
the job of the community you put them
into.
So I think it's,
you know,
it's very,
very important to do the best he can,
uh,
to recognize the fact that it might not
always work out to be as,
uh,
as understanding about those times as
you are about the times when it does
work out.
Uh,
and to,
you know,
nurture your people and train your
people as much as you can.
You know,
there's been a change and although I
probably a change,
again given the recession,
but go into the recession,
there was,
there was a change in perception,
I think about how people graduated
college and came into the workforce.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
you know,
some said that they must pant pamper
generation ever that,
you know,
the,
the baby boom generation was used to not
having a particularly huge amount of
nurturing and you know,
tender loving care and so over,
uh,
compensated for that.
And there are children where the benefit
of that,
so they're probably the most adjusted
generation,
uh,
and they have a very clear understanding
that there's a work life balance,
God forbid.
Uh,
but it,
it makes it more difficult for them on
the one hand to come into a institutions
that perhaps don't value that and quite
the same way that they do the other
hand,
it makes it very difficult for the
organizations to understand exactly
what's motivating this next generation.
So you've got,
you know,
generational issue intertwined with
everything else that's,
that's gone on in the past.
And so,
you know,
I don't know,
there's a,
a one silver bolt solution that's
probably not,
but being aware of that and try to
understand that and,
and helping folks on both sides,
uh,
move through that,
that process,
uh,
I think is a,
is is,
is a necessary thing.
You know,
I think there's ways to get people over
that hump that it's not all about,
you know,
everything helping you win
unfortunately,
and get organizations to understand that
there might need to be a little more
helping new people when,
uh,
and once you get past that initial
foray,
you can have some very,
very effective,
very good,
uh,
employees.
Yeah.
The other thing I think I,
I should mention here is one of the,
the core thoughts that we go into
employee interactions with.
Uh,
and that is the notion that,
that nobody is coming to work,
uh,
as at the end has a top of the list.
The reason they're going to work is
nothing to do with the level of the
company,
right?
They're going to work because,
you know,
they want to feed themselves and their
families.
Uh,
as the first priority.
The second priority is they're going to
work because they want to improve their
career.
They weren't able to feed and clothe and
take care of their families better and
better and better as they move along.
You know,
and the third reason they're going to
work is so it's,
they enjoy this better than they enjoy
that.
So if I can be,
or the company can be the fourth reason,
that's a really good thing.
And understanding that and being up
front about it,
I think is also really good thing.
It allows a more honest set of
communications and of course allows you
to have the conversation about,
look,
you know,
the reason that we all want to succeed
is that by succeeding together,
we're all succeed more by succeeding
individually.
We'll all succeed less.
So succeeding together you will a,
make more money.
B,
have,
you know,
a better credential and move forward in
your career with and see,
have a lot more fun.
Uh,
so you know,
all of your three first things will
basically be addressed.